la france a vibré au mois d'août au
rythme des jeux olympiques avec 40
millions de téléspectateurs en audience
cumulée sur l'ensemble de la compétition
certains sports ont pu se voir offrir
une fenêtre médiatique
une exposition qui a un impact sur les
clubs locaux en termes de licenciés le
judo porté par un teddy riner médaillé
d'or chez les plus de 100 kg s'attend à
voir arriver de jeunes judokas
contaminés par la rigueur manière qu'ils
nous disent teddy riner autres sports
boosté par les géo la boxe la france a
collecté six médailles dont deux en or
pendant cette olympiade tony hawk à
originaire des yvelines est devenu une
superstar de la discipline le boxing
club de saint quentin en yvelines
s'attend à accueillir 40 % de licenciés
supplémentaires pour cette nouvelle
saison
j'ai beaucoup de coups de téléphone déjà
énormément voilà je pense qu'on fasse ça
difficile vu la taille de la salle mais
on peut même doubler l'effectif qu'on a
là on a à peu près 120 licenciés on peut
en tout arrive à le doubler mais après
faut pousser les murs l'équitation sport
pratiqué par plus de 680 mille licenciés
dont 22 milles dans les yvelines devrait
également profiter des trois médailles
glanées au brésil par les cavaliers
foncé il est très difficile à évaluer
parce qu'on est déjà le troisième sport
national en nombre de licenciés est le
premier chez les filles donc c'est c'est
un peu compliqué les clubs sont pleins à
craquer puis il faut avoir aussi là la
cavalerie pour pour assumer assumer
cette augmentation donc c'est c'est
difficile à évaluer mais effectivement
on sent que il ya du on espère en tous
les cas qui aura un effet plus haut
niveau de la médiatisation un bilan
définitif sera dressé dans tous ces
sports d'ici novembre avec la fin des
inscriptions annuelles